what's going on everybody Derek Jackson
no no that was just it's just welcome to
ABBA's field trip so if you want to work
Derek Jackson is I won't say team
Jackson team Jackson that's what you
rejected what's happening uh
[ __ ] uh he's a dating coach uh who
basically spent most of his career uh
[ __ ] on black men and then
constantly uplifting black women through
that process basically Brown nosy
um afterwards a lot of men were like
watch out ladies and scam artist turns
out uh you know he was cheating on his
wife the entire time cheated with
multiple women came out with a lame ass
apology but now they're trying to work
it out at least that's what's been the
case for the last year and uh recently
he announced his divorce after after he
got caught cheating again and that's the
thing is that yeah
the timeline is clear yeah a couple
blocks picked it up and said hey Jack we
found out you cheating again and my
Mains came on Instagram the next day and
said listen it's very difficult to
announce the fact that me and my wife
are separating after none of this [ __ ]
matters that we shouldn't care it
doesn't matter
until you scold [ __ ] because
they're doing the same thing you're
doing when you putting yourself in a
position where you're saying you're
doing this and you're wrong you're doing
this and you're wrong you're doing this
and you're wrong you're a scam artist
hypocrisy there you go
Jackson is always somebody he was always
somebody that I liked simply because I
knew he was a married black man to a
black woman like he is a black man who
looks the [ __ ] good he's married to a
black woman who looks the [ __ ] good he
is faithful to that black woman I I just
know that based on because I've had
conversations with him outside that
outside
outside of the internet
I mean how was your field trip that was
I think all the guys got to sit back
kick up her legs
let the ladies process all this you know
ladies you might be done processing no
you're not you're gonna keep processing
because we had to endure him for many
years you're gonna have to process for
just as many while we just go I told you
so so let's enjoy this okay we're not
done so yeah I messaged Derek you
message Derek I miss Derek after all
these years I mean I got so excited by
this news I had to just let him know how
I felt tell you none of the time oh
you beat this [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you oh
[Music]
you cold oh I'm I'm actually jealous I
didn't do it he wrote black man don't
cheat
get off me
team Jackson what's happening team
Jackson what's happening team Jackson
what's happening team Jackson what's
happening
that's what I listen when I'm saying to
you that you took a whole ass field trip
with that [ __ ] we're we're seeing that
look at the trees look at the animal oh
look that's a baboon that's
again healed together without hurting
each other my new book is available now
at the link down in the caption and by
the way I'm gonna speak in third person
Power Man treats you is how he feels
about you I just had to co-sign that bro
like that's some of the real [ __ ] I've
ever heard or if he treats you like you
a dummy that's how he feels about you
but you know I'm tired of seeing y'all
settle for these lanes and these scrubs
they treat y'all like [ __ ] in it while
the Jared Jackson was telling on the man
that he was himself the entire time
Action Jackson
team Jacks Abba
you never miss can't keep it in this
dick what pants Jack
I can't keep it in this dick true about
it he this whole time writing books a
cheating man's heart you know how many
books this man has no we've got
a cheating man's heart
part one
's heart
part two
a cheating man's heart part three [ __ ]
I'm a cheating man what's up like you
know that's part four but anyways all we
need to know he's not done I still
deserve it and by it he means anybody
who's not his wife's [ __ ] I've come too
far
you can't make this up flag on the play
I still want it he's talking about that
side [ __ ] okay that was a single
mothers are for grown man only
you know he's slitting somebody's with
Yips and said that [ __ ] before he [ __ ]
her like yo these are crazy oh this is
my favorite one this is crazy
hey quit don't forget your crown
don't forget your crowd
don't forget your crown don't forget
your crown queen
don't forget your crown hey yo ma
Yo Ma you dropped some yo don't forget
your crowns
oh you're not gonna respond okay Queen
have a blessed day heal together without
hurting each other
well I guess that didn't work my nigga's
getting divorced when these dudes out
here who are really going hard for their
girl again don't forget your clown where
I go way more in depth about how to
avoid the guys that are actually trash
y'all settling and fighting over these
dudes that make you feel like you're
just a runner-up with these other chicks
when in the beginning he was telling you
that you was the baddest you was the
realest you was the best you was wifey
you was this that and the other but then
when y'all get together he gets
inconsistent and starts making you feel
like you average and you if you ever
have questions about how a man feels
about you ask his actions that's gonna
tell you everything you need to know
heal together without hurting each other
is actually half off right now at the
link down in the caption but if I do
don't [ __ ] with you [ __ ] he'll ignore
you he'll cuss you out call you out your
name you'll cheat on you even put his
hands on you the last thing a dude is
not going to do if he's really into you
is make it seem to other girls like he's
still on the market even if there's no
title yet it ain't gonna happen so if
you're dealing with confused men don't
act confused whenever he leaves you
heartbroken in your time wasted cause
that's what confused men do put it like
this if the infractions are starting to
straight up humiliate you it's time to
let him go but the truth is and I'm
saying it here now is that Derek Jackson
was involved with other women cheating
Affair Jeremiah won't even speak in the
third person yeah
good Lord you know what I don't even
think that I could really enjoy this
that much
I think I've already enjoyed it as much
as I could like
at this point I'm just like
oh you feel for him no
no
you know what it's like I figured it out
it's like when you pull up a porno then
you bust a nut and then you sit there
with your dick in your hands and you're
like bro why do I do this like this why
is my dick still in my hands formula you
know what I mean you know I mean like
it's over
clean up [ __ ] let's go that's why I'm
thinking myself right now like it's over
okay heal together without hurting each
other my new book is available now at
the link down in the caption but let me
say this I have no sympathy
for a man who finds it to be difficult
to be faithful after being in a
promiscuous lifestyle and neither should
you nobody told you to be promiscuous
before the relationship and nobody made
you be monogamous with just her you
don't want to let another man have her
now
if you're wondering what's going on with
the wife
uh
uh she's lost her mind no
really
every person speaking against the names
danaya Jackson and Derek Jackson in
mockery accusation Slanders and lies May
the mercies of God be withdrawn from you
may your husbands and wives become
widows let your children become
fatherless let your seed become
vagabonds on the earth let the words of
your mouth and your words of your hands
be returned back to you let it go down
your throat and choke you slowly until
your days become few on the earth the
word of God says touch not my anointed
and do my prophets no harm you've been
warned and if you want to know where
that is at in the Bible go to Psalm 109
go to Psalm 35 go to Psalm 140 go to
Psalm 141.
and keep our names out of your mouth in
the name of Jesus no no no no no no no
no no no no no no you can't
you can't no you can't do slavery in the
name of Jesus you can't kill in the name
of Jesus you can't do threats like that
in the name of Jesus making it in the
name of Jesus don't make it good all
right it's you still you wow no all
right you know what I mean you can and
she did wow
using the scriptures
wow but no no but she was she was like
that I don't think she she was like that
before I don't know this should look
like a broker remember when she was like
dressing all day of salvation
happened after the cheating yes but that
that was that I mean this is the next
level I mean she wishing this on people
oh yeah that's another level yeah and we
and when he's only Built to excel in the
playground he's gonna do a whole lot
better with the monkey bars and the
swings and you know the Merry-Go-Round
that he's going to do with a woman like
you who's built on business who's built
on breaking generational curses of
continued dysfunction who's built on
building a Empire and Legacy you can't
do that with somebody who can only Excel
when it's play play time I play play
pause I never tell them to Halt stop
cause I drop and roll with the truth
hot
they call me in the streets
sizzling
like who Sizzler
boom boom
shalakalaka boom
hey hey hey my [ __ ] that was a good
assistance okay
my mom said what did you say say I said
I ain't trying to get no beating though
oh God damn she said
you gonna get that beauty though
and I'm like damn Ma I just wanted to
play play but you know what they say say
what they say never mess with Mama
because today's her day day um
I came for the fans who came for him
Battle Raps let's go I came with some
hams okay Thanksgiving yes go we here
with some Lambs listen but we ain't
getting slaughtered look hey boy you
know what time it is what time is it
play play oh
God damn that was hot that made no sense
I made it that was hot
all right there's a trip that little
Memory Lane because it's been an ongoing
saga you know 41. this is a Victory lap
and an extra so here's the more serious
side I guess yeah go ahead
from my perspective
I don't think there's anything wrong
with a man wanting to uplift women and
to spend a lot of time on that or make
that their mission I just think it looks
very suspicious to me when you are
extremely uncharitable to men
and you're extremely charitable to women
like you don't understand the male
perspective then I just think you're
brown-nosing I think you know every time
you describe as a woman he's like when
you're built on the idea of breaking
genital generational wealth while he's
on the shooting from the monkey bars
like a little child it's like why is it
always these two extremes where it's
like this boss independent Beyonce type
woman and then the dude is some loser
with his bias below his knees and like
three murder raps so I like why is that
always the example selling books he's
selling books and this I don't even
think he believes what he says I agree I
was gonna say
if somebody has a financial interest in
selling you products
yeah yeah I see you just be careful I
see just be careful okay I listening to
his videos I'm like bro he's doing too
much this dude this dude Brown Nelson
yeah no this dude Brown was a little bit
too hard so I've been a little bit
obsessed to him
um and then with all this Scandal stuff
it was just
I was just thou doth protest too much
which is this I said are you quoting the
scriptures too no that's Shakespeare
okay yeah yeah I was like God damn which
is just to say like you're doing too
much
you're doing too much what are you
really hiding
all this extra extra it's like you're
doing too much the ladies like it
because it reaffirms what they really
want to believe on the inside but
is it the truth
or does it work
this thing that's all I'm trying to get
at you know and with all this and what
kind of stuff do I really can't not
really
yeah I mean at the end of the day we can
all sit here and laugh about it but a
divorce means a family is breaking up
means that children are gonna have to
deal with certain things and he's got
multiple children there's nothing to be
happy about you know
um and I don't wish that on any family
in that regards nor do I wish it on any
marriage so I sit back and I look at
this and I'm just like breath you didn't
have to do all this I get you want to
make some money I guess you got an
audience you want to appeal to I'm sure
you would have retained many of them if
you were more reasonable instead you had
to pretend to put on this fake persona
and guess what when it turns out you're
the perfect man that you pretended to be
the energy the internet is going to come
for that ass oh they gonna come for you
and they will not stop they will not
miss either you are officially a meme
but you know what
I don't even think this hurts him that
bad you wanna know why no because
[ __ ] are going to talk about
this too because a lot of people want to
hear the lies they want to be told these
lies because it makes them feel good so
this is gonna blow over and he's gonna
go back to making his cheesy [ __ ]
videos where he's warning women about
men who are him
and
the World's Gonna keep pushing ah B
listen it looks exponential for people
who follow social media the stuff that
she's been posting you can tell that
she's angry she's lashing out of
everything it don't seem like she doing
great my [ __ ] no I don't think she is
but then whatever okay let let's say the
mental health that was there before
you put a girl through these kind of
Dramas and things like that in the
public eye a sane person
will have breakdowns over [ __ ] like this
yeah now somebody who got issues see how
you're casting spells wishing death on
people that's not small in the name of
Jesus hey you know hey that's the thing
is that like that's the thing we all
broken and [ __ ] we all got [ __ ] to deal
with we all have our issues and stuff
like that
whenever you're trying to scroll
[ __ ] for the thing that you
doing it that's that's weird whatever
yeah yeah but that's it so I know
everybody wanted us to do like 30
victory laps I don't have it to be
honest with you like I said I've been
over this one I had my fun back then so
at this point this is just oh and you
have fun yeah is it this is this thing
that that was about to happen inside he
is here's what he is and there's plenty
of more like these you know what is a
real discussion what is a real
discussion breath relationship
relationship gurus needs to go
all those gurus needs to religion zero
certification just talking out their ass
on a mic okay and they're trying to sell
you products afterwards I don't care if
they just gotta pay yeah one thing
[ __ ] selling you products
convincing you that they're experts like
literally self-defining themselves as
such that's a little weird same thing
online you can have an opinion that's a
different thing right I think that every
time you snip your phone toe in the
water that's what causes tokens okay
that's an opinion same thing but I need
a doctor
there's a difference Joe schmoe saying
some [ __ ] is not the same as our
doctor said you call yourself an expert
same thing with life coaches there's too
much of life coaches out there talking
about know what you need shut the [ __ ]
up yeah and even in relationship like
you don't know what goes on in real life
you don't know okay that's one thing the
second thing is what works for one
person doesn't necessarily work for
other people that's it like there's not
there's not a key there's not one key
you know there's tools but not Keys uh
in this book there's a perfect nah no
there no there isn't stop
anyways Hey listen listen just careful
relationship gurus are like these all
crypto experts coming to find out a
little while later they're just a giant
frauds and they go into jail now you see
what's going on in there they go in
their jail now are you okay you see
what's going on going to jail now you
see what's going on in the crypto yeah
there's a lot of frauds out here a lot
of [ __ ] was in my DM talking
about yeah you want to learn about this
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
whatever and I'm like yo where where you
at now what should be the criterias of
what to be a relationship Guru no no no
no no no no no no no no let's
participate because there's too much
there's too many parameters parameters
there's too many parameters with within
a relationship
the different type of people that you're
going to meet a the other different type
of people that's gonna meet B so you got
two different type of people that have
to there's too many there's too much
there's too much
you talk just just you talk about a
binary relationship like a CIS
relationship okay you have the girl all
the type of girls of different girls
with all that different type of issues
that they might have with all the
different type of backgrounds then you
have guys you know what you know what
you need to be to be a a a good Guru
of psychologists you need to do seven
[ __ ] years of of psychology and
become a uh therapist a psychologist in
in uh relationship that that are and
even then
and even then they can be wrong so a
normal Joe that don't have the
credentials that have never been to
school that doesn't study psychology
that just goes on whims of Life yeah no
no no no we're not doing that when you
said you know you have to be in order to
be fit to be a relationship Guru and in
my head I was thinking
God
really
God God
knows your heart you had the one that
went inside a relationship and didn't
bring it into Mary made a reversion and
I had jolten that Joseph the cook that's
that's your God no that's not my God
that's they got you know that's that's
some folks got and that's your God
that's the one you grew up with that's
not mine okay mine didn't do that okay
so you're so God you claim your god dude
I thought I thought you was nine what
was it talking about oh my God